[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Christian Siebers guten Abend
in allen es wird einfacher in
Deutschland es wird unkomplizierter in
diesem Land das detaillierte Regelungen
doch so sehr liebt wenn das keine
Aufmacher Nachricht heute ist dann weiß
ich auch nicht für 49 Euro kreuz und
quer im Nahverkehr unterwegs Bund und
Länder haben sich geeinigt auf ein neues
deutschland-ticket das ab Januar kommen
könnte es gibt noch ein paar
Finanzfragen zu klären aber man kann
jetzt schon sagen dass Stirnrunzeln vor
dicht bedruckten Tariftabellen und
verwirrenden Netzplänen hat ein Ende ob
damit wirklich attraktive Zeiten im
öffentlichen Nahverkehr beginnen ist
allerdings nicht automatisch sicher
keine
in welche Richtung wird sich Deutschland
in punkto Mobilität entwickeln das
Nachfolgemodell zum 9 euro-ticket sei
eine der größten verkehrsreform so
meinte heute zumindest Bundesminister
Wissing mit dem Schönheitsfehler oder
ist es mehr dass der Kompromiss der
heute im Bremerhaven gefunden wurde die
vielen anderen Probleme im Nahverkehr
nicht löst das nutzt das schönste Ticket
nichts wenn kein Bus fährt die
öpnv-unternehmen haben nach wie vor
damit zu tun dass es Mindereinnahmen
durch Corona gibt auch leiden sie unter
den steigenden Energiepreisen daher
wollen die Verkehrsminister der
Bundesländer das Ticket nur auf den Weg
bringen wenn der Bund beim nächsten
Treffen mit dem Ministerpräsidenten
Zusagen für mehr Geld für Busse und Bahn
und ein besseres Verkehrsnetz auf dem
Land einhält der Bundesverkehrsminister
versprach seine Unterstützung an der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz teilnehmen
ich habe die Interessen der Länder immer
vertreten weil ich weiß wie wichtig es
ist dass die Regionalisierungsmittel für
eine zur Verfügung stehen um eine
ausreichende und gute
Organisation und Finanzierung dass das
ÖPNV sicherzustellen heute aber erst
einmal Entscheidung für das digitale
Ticket für 49 Euro es soll monatlich
kündbar sein zum ersten Januar 2023
kommen und Bund und Länder wollen sich
die Kosten dafür teilen
Fahrgäste begrüßen das Ergebnis
auf jeden Fall 50 Euro ist zwar nicht so
gut wie 9 euro-ticket aber wenn man
durch ganz Deutschland tun kann sollte
man unbedingt ausprobieren das ist mir
zu teuer weil ich nicht so oft mit dem
Bus fahre also da vielleicht wäre es
immer nutzt ist das ja vielleicht ganz
gut ich habe das 9 euro-ticket auch
schon genutzt und habe mich sehr darüber
gefreut natürlich könnte man dann was an
den Verbindungen verbessern der Verband
Deutscher Verkehrsunternehmen schloss
sich dem generellen Lob an Strich aber
die immense Bedeutung der noch
ausstehenden Finanzhilfen heraus
diese ganzen kleineren auch privaten
Busunternehmen und so in Deutschland die
unheimlich wichtig sind für das
Gesamtsystem schülerverkehre und so die
machen echt dann die Grätsche um es mal
ganz Platz zu sagen ja die sind von den
Fahrgeldeinnahmen abhängig und wenn sie
natürlich die Fahrgeldeinnahmen
künstlich runterdrücken und die Kosten
steigen extrem durch Energie und so
weiter dann entsteht ein riesen Delta
ja und das muss irgendwie ausgeglichen
werden die Finanzierungslücke über die
sich die Ministerpräsidenten mit dem
Bund verständigen müssen beträgt rund 3
Milliarden Euro auch um etwa gestiegene
Energiekosten aufzufangen
ein Schritt nach vorne weitere werden
noch folgen müssen
European Sky Shield damit wollen sich
Deutschland und 14 weitere europäische
Länder vor Luftangriffen schützen das
klingt entschlossen ist aber bislang nur
eine Absichtserklärung ein sogenannter
Letter of Intent und Papier ist geduldig
wie das hightech-abwehrsystem aussehen
soll wer die horrenden Kosten übernimmt
alles noch offen und noch ein Satz in
der Erklärung der Verteidigungsminister
heute lässt aufhorchen das neue System
solle Lücken schließen das heißt ja
nichts anderes als das aktuell große
Lücken da sind ich spreche gleich mit
der deutschen Verteidigungsministerin
erst Florian neuhahn aus Brüssel
und jetzt werden wir diesen besonderen
Moment diesen Start dieser Initiative
auch noch in einem Foto festhalten und
ich darf euch alle Bitten nach draußen
zu kommen zum familyfoto
als wäre sie die Gastgeberin Brüssel das
Hauptquartier der NATO heute morgen die
deutsche Verteidigungsministerin weist
den Weg in einem Bereich in dem Irland
lange hinterherhinkte
was wenn Raketen auf Europa fliegen dann
zeigt sich im nato-sprech eine
fähigkeitslücke übersetzt es wäre ein
echtes Problem
die Lücke im Bereich Luftverteidigung
war bekannt auch dass Deutschland immer
weiter und weiter Fähigkeiten abgebaut
hat der Problemdruck war einfach nicht
da man konnte sich nicht vorstellen dass
irgendein Szenario irgendwann mal wieder
auftauchen würde indem das tatsächlich
relevant sein würde nun das hat sich
geändert Ende August in Prag der
Bundeskanzler schlägt eine europäisches
Flugabwehrsystem vor nur sechs Wochen
später kann Christine Lambrecht in
Brüssel ein Papier unterschreiben und
mit kaum verborgenem stolz verkünden es
sein
mittlerweile 15 Staaten die gemeinsam
diese Anstrengung angehen wollen in
Bezug auf die Luftverteidigung die
Lücken zu schließen European Sky Shield
europäischer Schutzschirm so heißt das
Projekt neben Deutschland machen 13
NATO-Staaten mit darunter Großbritannien
und mehrere osteuropäische Staaten dazu
der nato-anwärter Finnland nicht dabei
ist Frankreich das auf die eigene
nukleare Abschreckung setzt und Polen
alle anderen wollen nun gemeinsam neue
Waffensysteme Einkaufen Favorit der
deutschen das US israelische System
Arrow 3 das Raketen sogar im Weltraum
vernichten kann
es hat eine Reichweite von bis zu 2.400
km und kann Raketen auch außerhalb der
Atmosphäre in einer Höhe von 100
Kilometern stoppen Arrow 3 Raketen
tragen ein sogenanntes kill wie hickle
einen Gefechtskopf der den feindlichen
Sprengkopf beim Aufprall zerstört
dazu kommt ein unschlagbarer Vorteil
wir reden hier von einem System was
bereits auf dem Markt ist was verfügbar
ist und diesen sicheren Schutz bietet
ohne eine lange Erprobungsphase fragt
sich nur ob jetzt noch eine lange
Diskussionsphase folgt den
entscheidenden Fragen haben sie in
Brüssel heute nicht geklärt etwa wer wie
viel zahlt
Christine Lambrecht ist die
bundesverteidigungsministerin und jetzt
bei uns danke dafür guten Abend Frau
lambrecht
einen schönen guten Abend ich würde gern
mit Ihnen über die Sicherheit der
Ukraine reden und über unsere Sicherheit
hier das hängt ja beides zusammen sind
aber dennoch zwei unterschiedliche
Herausforderungen wenn sie zurückdenken
Frau Lamprecht als sie das Amt
übernommen haben das ist ja nicht mal
ein Jahr her können Sie den Deutschen
immer noch versprechen dass wir hier
sicher sind
wir können zumindest gewährleisten dass
die Bundeswehr dafür sorgen kann dass
die Landes- und bündnisverteidigung
gewährleistet ist ja das kann ich
zusagen
jetzt ist es ja ein Thema aktuell auf
der Agenda über das wir über das auch
ich ehrlich gesagt mir nie vorgestellt
habe dass wir hier mal drüber reden
müssen die Gefahr eines Atomkriegs ist
plötzlich Thema heute auch bei den bei
der NATO bei den Beratung an denen sie
teilgenommen haben sie haben heute
gesagt die atomdrohungen Russlands
sollten wir nicht auf die leichte
Schulter nehmen erklären Sie uns doch
bitte was sie damit konkret meinen
mir ist ganz wichtig dass wir diese
Drohungen ernst nehmen dass wir sie
nicht abtun dass wir uns davon aber auch
auf keinen Fall lähmen lassen sondern
dass wir sehr genau beobachten welche
Bewegungen beispielsweise in Russland
geschehen welche Bewegungen bei Übungen
erfolgen und ob sich daraus Rückschlüsse
ziehen lassen auf mögliche Initiativen
das haben wir solche Informationen haben
wir bisher nicht weder wir noch andere
alliierte aber wir müssen wachsam sein
wir müssen genau beobachten und wir
müssen vor allen Dingen ganz klar und
deutlich machen der Einsatz von
nuklearen Waffen überschreitet jede rote
Grenze und deswegen ist es so wichtig
dass das auch Putin immer wieder
signalisiert wird und genau das
geschieht haben Sie den Eindruck dass es
bei ihm angekommen
ich denke schon dass deutlich wurde dass
die NATO geschlossen ist das auch
innerhalb der Europäischen Union
geschlossen ist und das ist auch Signale
von vermeintlich Verbündeten gibt die
vielleicht anders erwartet wurden also
auch die Reaktionen aus China
beispielsweise oder anderen Staaten die
sind schon sehr deutlich dass hier
wirklich eine rote Linie überschritten
wird und es ist gut so dann das wäre
eine verheerende Situation und dazu
dürfen wir es nicht kommen lassen jetzt
ist es heute bei der NATO wir müssen
dringend die Lücken bei unserer
Luftverteidigung schließen das heißt ja
zunächst mal das enorme Lücken bestehen
das ist richtig und Olaf Scholz hat
darauf zurecht in seiner Rede in Prag
vor wenigen Wochen hingewiesen und es
ist wichtig dass wir das Aussprechen
aber dass wir dann auch handeln und
deswegen sind wir da als Deutschland
jetzt auch in die Führung gegangen und
haben andere Staaten aufgefordert auch
gebeten mit uns zusammen diese Lücken zu
schließen in Bezug auf die
Luftverteidigung wir sind schon in
Gesprächen wir haben schon früh
koordiniert damit es jetzt eben auch
losgehen kann und aufgrund unserer
Initiative für so einen European Sky
Shield haben sich jetzt mittlerweile
jetzt schon 14 Staaten angeschlossen wir
sind also jetzt schon 15 und können
loslegen damit endlich diese Lücke
geschlossen wird das Ganze wird immens
teuer so viel ist klar die Zahl von 20
Milliarden kursiert es ist aber im
Moment gar nicht auszumachen wie teuer
es am Ende tatsächlich wird Deutschland
haben sie jetzt mehrfach gesagt soll die
Führungsrolle bei all dem haben heißt
dass das Deutschland auch zahlt
Deutschland koordiniert Deutschland das
ist unsere Führung in dieser Frage dass
wir schon in die Gespräche gegangen sind
in Bezug auf die Beschaffung von
womöglich einem error-3-system aber auch
Patriots von Iris t da gehen wir in die
Führung aber natürlich übernehmen wir
nicht die komplette Finanzierung so ist
das ganze auch nicht angedacht aber wenn
wir gemeinsam bestellen wenn wir
gemeinsam beschaffen dann haben wir auch
die Möglichkeit durch eine hohe
Stückzahl eben auch andere Preise zu
erzielen und das ist der Vorteil dieses
gemeinsamen Handels was jetzt ganz
unmittelbar passieren muss weil
Lamprecht ist das die Ukraine eine
funktionierende Flugabwehr bekommt wie
wichtig das ist haben wir diese Woche ja
gerade noch mal gesehen wann kommt denn
der Tag an dem die Ballungsräume dort
zumindest geschützt sein werden sind das
jetzt noch Tage oder sind das Monate
also wir haben jetzt gerade ganz aktuell
ein hochmodernes ein sehr komplexes
System geliefert nämlich iriste
von einer Stadt von ungefähr 230.000
Einwohnern wenn es perfekt funktioniert
Kiew hat 2,9 Millionen Einwohner
und deswegen wird es auch nicht nur
dieses eine System geben sondern im
nächsten Jahr kommen drei weitere und
deswegen werden auch andere Verbündete
dazu war auch die Ukraine
Unterstützungsgruppe ja gestern zusammen
und hat sich erneut getroffen und
diesmal mittlerweile in insgesamt 50
Staaten und andere Staaten liefern
ebenfalls und das ist so wichtig dass
wir uns abstimmen dass wir gemeinsam
handeln dass eben jeder die
Möglichkeiten auslotet und dann auch
nutzt die die der jeweilige Staat hat um
die Ukraine zu Stütze unterstützen wir
machen das über ihre stee wir haben das
über beispielsweise auch die Geparden
gemacht und andere Staaten liefern jetzt
auch das ist dringend erforderlich aber
ich hatte gefragt wann ist denn der
Zeitpunkt an dem zumindest die
Ballungszentren in der Ukraine dann
geschützt sind Jahre Monate was sagen
sie den Menschen dort
es darf keine Jahre dauern sondern es
muss jetzt sehr sehr zügig gehen und es
geht auch zügig ich habe ja gesagt in
dieser Kontaktgruppe in dieser
Unterstützungsgruppe da ist sehr viel
Bewegung da ist ja viel Engagement zu
spüren gewesen gerade angesichts der
Bild die wir in den letzten Tagen ganz
aktuell auch gesehen haben
recht ich versuche einfach nur
rauszufinden mit was konkret wir da
rechnen können
wenn alle Nationen sowie zugesagt auch
liefern aber da sind natürlich auch die
Nationen auch auf die Industrie jeweils
angewiesen aber wenn in im Rahmen der
Zusage geliefert wird dann können wir
ziemlich breit abdecken dass die Ukraine
geschützt wird ein vollständigen
100-prozentigen Schutz werden Sie
wahrscheinlich nicht erreichen können
aber das was dazu gesagt wurde das ist
schon sehr beeindruckend sagt die
bundesverteidigungsministerin Christine
Lamprecht SPD vielen Dank für das
Gespräch heute Abend
ich danke Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir aus Termin
Gründen am frühen Abend aufgezeichnet
und wir bleiben jetzt noch beim Thema
mit dir Gundula Kreml Chef Putin und der
türkische Präsident Erdogan haben bei
einem Treffen offenbar nicht über
Bemühungen für ein Ende des russischen
Krieges gesprochen nach Angaben aus
Moskau ging es bei der Begegnung in
Kasachstan um einen Ausbau der
wirtschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit Putin
schlug vor die Türkei zu einem
umschlagland für russisches Gas zu
machen zugleich haben sich im Gegenzug
die türkischen Exporte nach Russland
nahezu verdoppelt
seit heute fließt erstmals Gas aus
Frankreich direkt nach Deutschland das
teilte der französische gasnetzbetreiber
Gerte Gas mit geplant sind Lieferungen
von bis zu 100 Gigawattstunden täglich
das entspricht rund 3% der Menge die
Deutschland derzeit täglich importiert
die Gasspeicher hierzulande sind
mittlerweile zu mehr als 95% gefüllt
mit großer Mehrheit hat die
unvollversammlung Russlands
völkerrechtswidrige Annexionen
ukrainischer Gebiete verurteilt und für
ungültig erklärt 143 der 193
Mitgliedstaaten stimmten für die
Resolution fünf Länder dagegen 35
enthielten sich der Beschluss ist
völkerrechtlich nicht bindend gilt aber
als starkes politisches Zeichen
in Washington hat der
Untersuchungsausschuss zum Angriff auf
das Kapitol neue Ermittlungsergebnisse
vorgestellt der Ausschuss stimmte dabei
überraschend dafür Ex-Präsident Trump
vorzuladen er solle sich so wörtlich für
seine Taten verantworten ihm wird eine
erhebliche Beteiligung an den
Ereignissen vom 6 Januar 2021
vorgeworfen damals stürmten radikale
trump-anhänger das Kapitol während dort
der Wahlsieg beiden endgültig bestätigt
werden sollte
es wird viele Deutsche
Immobilienbesitzer freuen die
Abgabefrist der für viele sehr
aufwendigen grundsteuererklärung wird
von Ende Oktober bis Ende Januar 2023
verlängert darauf haben sich die Länder
Finanzminister verständigt bis
vergangene Woche hatte nicht einmal ein
Drittel aller Haus- und
Wohnungseigentümer die online-erklärung
abgegeben der Bundestag hat in erster
Lesung über die Reformen zum neuen
Bürgergeld und zum Wohngeld beraten
letzteres war weitgehend unsträssig über
das Bürgergeld aber lieferten sich
Regierung und Opposition einen heftigen
Schlagabtausch die Union kritisierte vor
allem die abgemilderten
Sanktionsmöglichkeiten die Linke mahnte
Betroffene blieben so arm wie zuvor das
Bürgergeld soll ab Januar Hartz IV
ersetzen und sieht eine Erhöhung der
Regelsätze um monatlich 53 Euro vor
es ist so eine Sache mit den ganz großen
Zahlen in den Nachrichten je größer sie
sind desto schwerer fällt es Sie als
Summe vieler einzelner Schicksale zu
begreifen dabei geht es ja genau darum
viele einzelne Schicksale
828 Millionen Menschen müssen weltweit
hungern 200 Millionen mehr als noch vor
drei Jahren die meisten Betroffenen
besonders betroffenen Länder liegen in
Afrika das ist eine Situation die wir
uns hier bei allen Sorgen die wir haben
kaum vorstellen können wenn nicht mehr
genug zu essen da ist beziehungsweise
noch genug da wäre aber es nicht mehr zu
bezahlen ist die Welthungerhilfe spricht
heute von einer toxischen Mischung aus
kriegen und Krisen die zur Katastrophe
führt Präsidentin Marlen Thieme warnt
der Hunger weltweit nimmt dramatisch zu
wir können nicht sagen wir haben es
nicht gewusst unsere
afrika-korrespondentin Susann von
Lojewski war im Südsudan wo nicht die
Dürre das Problem ist sondern
verheerende Überschwemmungen
Allard Boll agai wartet durch den
Schlamm das Wasser jeden Tag jeden Tag
versucht sie ihr Haus in mabio im
Südsudan zu erreichen doch noch steht
das Wasser zu hoch sie schafft es nicht
irgendwo da hinten so zeigt sie muss es
sein jedes Jahr kommt hier die Flut doch
so schlimm war es noch nie
mein Mann sagt es gibt keine andere
Stück Land aber ich habe jede Hoffnung
verloren und gehe in die Stadt damit die
Regierung sich um mich kümmert den
Nachbarn von alat geht es nicht viel
besser ihr Haus steht doch bewohnen
können sie es nicht mehr die Familie
muss von wenigen hirsekörnern leben die
Pflanzen aber sind größtenteils verfault
am Himmel wartet der nächste Regen der
alles unter Wasser setzt und die Straßen
für die Helfer im Südsudan nahezu un
passierbar macht jetzt es ist
schrecklich schlecht in der Regelzeit
die meisten Regionen sind völlig
überflutet wir kommen nicht in die
Gemeinden die wirklich dringend Hilfe
brauchen das ist das eine das andere
Transportkosten für die waren die die
Communities brauchen sind eine sehr
große Herausforderung
hier im Kreiskrankenhaus von tonsch
verwalten Sie den Mangel Essen für
Erwachsene gibt es nicht alle
Medikamente sind Spenden 1,5 Millionen
Kinder so Schätzungen sind im
südsudan-mangel ernährt auch Boll seine
Mutter brachte ihn mit etwas mehr als
fünf Kilo in die Klinik viel zu wenig
für seine 11 Monate
niemand hilft mir alle im Dorf sind
betroffen und haben kein Essen weil die
Flut überall war kann niemand mir helfen
Assunta Adio koordiniert für die Region
tonnensch die Hilfe der
Nichtregierungsorganisationen allzu viel
kommt derzeit nicht alles ist schwierig
im jüngsten Staat der Welt die
politische Situation die Versorgungslage
die Transportwege und auch der Krieg im
fernen Europa hat Auswirkungen auf ihre
Arbeit
wir haben Krieg in der Ukraine das
trifft unsere Partner sie helfen nicht
wir geben Ihnen unsere Einschätzung und
bekommen keine Antwort wir versuchen
alles um den Menschen zu helfen aber die
NGO helfen uns aktuell nicht wir haben
keine Hilfe von unseren Partnern weil
sie kein Geld haben
Regina akiu konnte immerhin im Haus
ihrer Schwester unterkommen das was
deren kleine Stück Land hergibt verkauft
sie jeden Tag auf dem Markt immerhin
doch für ihre Kinder sieht Regina keine
Zukunft
du ich habe zwei Kinder die in Tornesch
zur Schule gehen aber jetzt nicht mehr
weil ich kein Geld habe
kein Geld um sie hinzuschicken auch hier
habe ich kein Geld selbst wenn der Regen
aufhört habe ich keine Kraft ein neues
Haus zu errichten doch
keine Kraft keine Hoffnung und nicht
genug Hilfe schon jetzt ist der Südsudan
eines der ärmsten Länder der Welt doch
die Lage könnte sich noch weiter
dramatisch verschaffen
sie haben gesehen wie wichtig die Arbeit
der Hilfsorganisation ist wenn Sie diese
vor Ort finanziell unterstützen wollen
dass Aktionsbündnis der
Katastrophenhilfe hat ein gemeinsames
Spendenkonto und hier ist die IBAN dazu
de65100-400-100 400 Stichwort ZDF Hunger
in Afrika alle Informationen wie immer
auch unter Spenden zdf.de
und hier bei uns noch mal du Gundula mit
dem Blick auf die Finanzmärkte da ist
die hohe Inflation weiterhin eines der
Themen für Deutschland bestätigte das
Statistische Bundesamt eine
Teuerungsrate von zehn Prozent im
September der höchste Stand in
Deutschland seit etwa 70 Jahren Frank
Bethmann geschüttelt hat es die Märkte
aber als heute auch die Inflationsdaten
aus den USA kamen ja und zwar zunächst
kräftig die Teuerung will auch in den
USA kaum Zurückgehen der Preisauftrieb
bleibt hoch bei über 8%. dabei weiß gar
nicht diese Zahl an sich sondern die
Erwartungshaltung man hatte einfach mit
einem stärkeren Rückgang gerechnet damit
dass die ungewöhnlich deutlich
leitzinsanhebungen der vergangenen
Monate eine erste preisdämpfende Wirkung
zeigen würden doch der chefvolks wird
der VP Punk Thomas gitzl fasst ist
vorhin ziemlich gut zusammen die Luft
entweicht nur langsam aus dem
inflationsballon Ernüchterung allerorts
hier in Frankfurt stürzt der DAX nachdem
die Zeichen auf Erholung standen
zunächst über 350 Punkte ab berappelt
sich dann aber und schließt sogar mit
über 180 Zählern im Plus der erste
Schritt also verflogen die Grundstimmung
aber bleibt schlecht inzwischen wird
fest damit gerechnet dass die
US-Notenbank Anfang November die
Zinsschraube weiter anziehen wird bis
aber endlich mal wieder die Preise an
der Ladentheke sinken dies wie jenseits
des Atlantiks werden wohl noch weitere
Monate vergehen die hohen Preise werden
zu einer immer größeren Belastung die
Ängste der deutschen das sind inzwischen
vor allem Geldsorgen wie aus einer
aktuellen Langzeitstudie der R+V
Versicherung hervorgeht auch nachzulesen
auf ZDF heute Frank Bethmann vielen Dank
zwei von drei internationalen
Fußballspielen mit deutscher Beteiligung
am Abend sind bereits beendet in der
Europa League gewann der SC Freiburg
auswärts in Frankreich gegen Nord 4 zu 0
und steht damit im Achtelfinale dagegen
hat in der Conference League der erste
fC Köln in Serbien 0:2 gegen Partisan
Belgrad verloren damit droht den Kölnern
das Aus in der Gruppenphase
nach der folgenschweren Bahn Sabotage am
Wochenende ermittelt nun die
Bundesanwaltschaft wegen des
anfangsverdachtes eines
verfassungsfeindlichen Hintergrundes am
Samstag hatten Unbekannte in Berlin und
Herne unverzichtbare Kabel für den
Zugfunk durchtrennt in weiten Teilen
Norddeutschlands stand daraufhin
Überstunden der Schienenverkehr still
im Zusammenhang mit einer mutmaßlich
geplanten Entführung von
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat
die Bundesanwaltschaft eine 75-jährige
Frau festnehmen lassen sie soll eine
staatsfeindliche Gruppe angeleitet und
dabei geholfen haben Waffen und
Sprengstoff zu besorgen der ehemaligen
Lehrerin war aufgrund ihres Reichsbürger
Gedankenguts bereits die Altersrente
aberkannt worden
der neue Innenminister von
Rheinland-Pfalz Michael Ebling hat
angekündigt den Untersuchungsausschuss
des Landtages zur Flutkatastrophe nach
Kräften zu unterstützen der bisherige
Oberbürgermeister von Mainz wurde von
Ministerpräsidentin Dreier zum
Nachfolger des zurückgetretenen
Ressortchefs lewens ernannt der
SPD-Politiker der als Vertrauter von
Dreier gilt will den Wiederaufbau im
Ahrtal vorantreiben
lesen stärkt die Seele hat schon voltair
gesagt gerade in Zeiten wie den
aktuellen kann es Wunder wirken was da
aus Papier entsteht bei uns im Kopf
Ablenkung Stärkung Richtung Claudio
Armbruster hat eine Autorin getroffen
die all das wunderbar beschreiben kann
die mit Thrillern bekannt geworden ist
und in ihrem neuen Buch aber die Kunst
des Verschwindens lehrt Melanie Rabe hat
einen Riss aufgetan in unserer Welt wie
sie sagt aber durch diesen Riss kommt
etwas helles
ist unser Lebensweg nur Zufall oder
Schicksal oder vielleicht Magie eine
Frau begegnet einer anderen Frau die ihr
Zwilling sein könnte es aber nicht ist
eine unbekannte und doch sofort
Seelenverwandte so beginnt diese
Geschichte die Welt ist eine andere als
noch vor wenigen Tagen als ob sich ein
Riss in ihre Oberfläche aufgetan hätte
durch den ich sehen kann ich glaube dass
eine einzige Freundlichkeit einen
Unterschied macht ich glaube tatsächlich
dass seine einzige Begegnung ein Leben
verändern kann
die Kunst des Verschwindens heißt dieser
Roman denn die gerade erst
kennengelernte Seelenverwandte
verschwindet so rätselhaft wie sie
aufgetaucht ist die zurückgelassene
beginnt zu suchen nach ihr und nach der
Lösung des Rätsels
ich denke ganz ganz häufig darüber nach
was so Scheidewege im Leben sind wenn
ich in an irgendeiner Stelle in meinem
Leben einer anderen Person begegnet wäre
oder wenn ich eine ganz ganz kleine
andere Entscheidung getroffen hätte wenn
irgendeine Kleinigkeit anders gewesen
wäre und dieses Verschwinden dieses ich
löse mich und meine Identität auf und
fange nochmal neu an das finde ich
einfach wahnsinnig spannend
Melanie Raabe 40 Jahre alt bei Jena
geboren und aufgewachsen
sie war Journalistin und schrieb
nebenbei nachts Thriller die heute
Bestseller sind in 20 Sprachen übersetzt
zum einen fasziniert mich dieser Prozess
weil es schön ist selbst in etwas zu
versinken obwohl man es gerade selbst
kreiert das ist ganz merkwürdig und
freutvoll kann ich gar nicht gut
beschreiben und dann fasziniert mich was
Bücher mit den Menschen machen wie sie
lesen ich finde es ein endloses
Faszinosum das ist nichts anderes ist
als dunkle schwarze Zeichen auf weißem
Grund auf Papier und wenn man die lange
genug anguckt fängt man an zu
halluzinieren und zu verreisen und was
zu fühlen
ihr neues Buch ist keine Thriller
sondern ein Roman im Hier und Jetzt in
der realen Welt aber mit zauberhaften
Ausflügen ins unwirkliche
magischer Realismus
[Musik]
ich glaube als das Buch geschrieben habe
und auch jetzt haben ganz viele von uns
das Gefühl dass die Welt nicht mehr so
ist wie wir sie kannten dass ich Dinge
wahnsinnig schnell verändern dass ich
irgendwie so ein Riss in der Realität
aufgetan hat und den wollte ich zeigen
und ich habe mir irgendwie
herausgenommen dass durch diesen Riss
nichts Dunkles kommt sondern etwas
helles schönes
die zu Beginn gestellte Frage ist alles
nur Zufall oder doch Schicksal wird
nicht beantwortet kann nie beantwortet
werden aber wenn Magie im Spiel ist kann
ein Happy End gezaubert werden in diesem
Roman sogar mehrere
ja Happy End nehmen wir gerne auch gerne
mehrfach und die Kollegin Maybrit Illner
holt uns dann wieder in die
tagesaktuelle Wirklichkeit heißer Krieg
in der Ukraine hybrider Krieg in Europa
Fragezeichen diskutiert ihre spannende
Runde gleich hier im ZDF Programm nach
uns beiden hier und um 0 Uhr ist dann
wieder Zeit für unser heute journal
Update mit Christopher Wehrmann vom
gesamten heute schon mal Team ein
angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend es wird jetzt wechselhaft
bei uns da ziehen doch einige Regenfälle
und Regenschauer über uns hinweg und bis
morgen Abend erreicht ein Tief Paris und
auf diesem regenvorschau Film sehen Sie
auch Schnee zum Beispiel in den
norwegischen Bergen was sie auf dem
regenvorschau vor nicht sehen sind die
Wolken die schauen wir uns jetzt
gemeinsam an denn da wird klar es ist
morgen eher ein trüber Freitag der uns
erwartet die Sonne werden sie da selten
mal zu Gesicht bekommen heute Nacht
fällt Regen besonders in der Südhälfte
und am Alpenrand kann es auch mal für
Blitz und Donner reichen an der
Ostseeküste gibt es auch einige
Regenschauer und unter diesen dichten
Wolken bleiben die Nachttemperaturen
deutlich milder sind in den vergangenen
Nächten uns erwarten Tiefstwerte von 12
Grad am Oberrhein und fünf Grad in der
Uckermark und morgen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 13 Grad in
Nordfriesland und 19 Grad zum Beispiel
in München und das wird ein eher drüber
Freitag und am Nachmittag kann es dann
besonders im Westen und dem Südwesten
auch mal kräftiger regnen die Sonne
werden sie allerdings auch zu Gesicht
bekommen ganz ansonsten wird das klappen
so zwei bis maximal vier Sonnenstunden
sind da möglich sonst ist die
sonnenausbeute eher mau aber das wird
sich schon über das Wochenende wieder
ändern und am Montag erwarten uns dann
doch wieder recht verbreitet vier bis
neun Sonnenstunden es wird nicht nur
deutlich sonniger sondern auch deutlich
wärmer nach einem durchwachsenen Samstag
gibt es schon am Sonntag bis zu 25 am
Montag bis zu 26 Grad guten Abend